I don't know how many more of these
videos how many more [ __ ] quotes how
many more t-shirts with a quote on it or
my [ __ ] Instagram put like how much
more motivation to [ __ ] need
[Music]
[Music]
yeah I don't I don't think the fitness
space is any different than any other
space I look at you know being
successful takes several different
variables
I think self-awareness is number one if
you don't know yourself and you don't
know what you're good at you've got no
shot because you're gonna be spinning
your wheels I think work ethic is at the
top you know I just nobody nobody
watching this right now knows anybody
that's successful at all that hasn't put
in serious amounts of work you might
know somebody that's rich but that may
be because mommy gave him or her the
money but nobody's made it without the
work so I think work ethic is immensely
important I think following attention I
think it's a bad idea to make a VHS tape
with your fitness workout in 2017 so I
think following the attention
understanding what's happening on
musically even snapchat Instagram
YouTube Facebook Twitter winner or the
attention of the consumers going so I
think attention work ethic
self-awareness those two those two or
three things really stand out to me as
the pillars of success without them
everything else is semantics I don't
know who else you've interviewed and
then I have little tactics you've got to
go in the clouds on this [ __ ] starts at
the top too many people are trying to
fix the faucet when the well is broken
you understand and so that's why my
answer to that question is those three
because they're heady they're heady but
it's the truth
like it starts and stops at those places
you suppose say you say oh yes how are
you speechless hello how are you
like Marian the orator of course I
didn't think you I'm real all right
I didn't think you're in town I'm
shocked at Hangtown myself thank you so
much France country it's my pleasure
pre-show pleasure you know listen I
understand where you're going with that
does it translate you know like take the
work ethic from the gym and put I just I
don't think that's real I think that's
why you have so many people that aren't
successful business people that are
tremendous in the gym and in great shape
I mean I don't know like you know I'd
love to rah-rah for you guys on this
film like take it from the gym
you know I I just I'm not even I'm
really like I can't motivate myself
right now to give a rah-rah on this like
to me it's like if you don't [ __ ] get
it like good like I don't like weird
about it like actually I'd prefer people
not be good at business that means I'll
make more like I don't know like I don't
know how many more of these videos
how many more [ __ ] quotes how many
more t-shirts with a quote on it or my
[ __ ] Instagram put like how much more
motivation to [ __ ] need like you live
one life it goes fast its life goes fast
like I just don't about like I don't
know like maybe it's gloomy outside on
the Mount I'm in a bad mood or something
maybe I'm a little tired out from d-roc
[ __ ] trying to get me to motivate
like like I don't know like I understand
the value of motivation I'm very I'm
very thankful that people get motivated
money I like it I like roaring I did it
as a kid for my wiffle ball team like
we'd be down to one going into nine like
right this is like we're gonna do it you
know like I love that I love that I just
um there's so much of it now there's so
much of it there's so much of it like
there's way more motivation right now
than execution and I don't I don't know
I don't know like I don't know what to
do to get you don't understand that you
have to do you have to do we're given
because I'm telling you right now I've
started bleeding it into my talks
is way this pressure to be entrepreneur
when you're actually a number four is
[ __ ] and it's and they're kids jumping
onto [ __ ] trains at your college
because they're not really entrepreneurs
they feel like they supposed to be but
they would have [ __ ] made a trillion
being number four and it's a real topic
okay and I will go give it and I will
help kids like there are a lot of people
who have some level of entrepreneurial
tendencies within an organization I
think I've been out there a lot on this
debate and I just don't think you're an
entrepreneur if you work in a company I
think it's just not the definition but
having entrepreneurial tendencies and
both of you have absolutely displayed
that in your careers from afar I know
that very closely with you less with you
but it's obvious and I even have
executives here for my company and they
all run the gamut
like some people yeah I think there are
people who have entrepreneurial
tendencies within an organization I do
believe that the bigger the company is
the less appetite that organization has
that for those people I think they have
a nice value prop for a little bit of
time but I do believe the more
entrepreneurial you are within an
organization the more likely that that
relationship will end eventually because
it is a conflict of DNA within that
structure the only interesting debate in
this world for me is people who like
wildly want to consider themselves
entrepreneurs when they're working
inside of a company to me that's that's
not real but entrepreneurial tendencies
and companies this and the other thing
yeah absolutely
entrepreneurship is fear you know what
being an entrepreneur is you can't blame
anybody else you can't blame the holding
company you can't put like when you look
you're like oh [ __ ] I'm last right and
so yeah there's and there's extreme and
by the way when you build brand within
an organization they let you do a ton of
[ __ ] but there's a big difference
between signing the front of a cheque
and signing the back of a cheque no but
it was [ __ ] good
really Rock
we need an Instagram on that [ __ ] that's
a first-timer but of how good right I
think the two big words that for
everybody's sitting here that you should
debate is really self-awareness and
regret I think those are the two words
that the matically play out for me if
I'm sitting here and deploying empathy
on whomever whatever you're doing one
you just know yourself like I think one
of the really scary things that's
happened last half-decade is people
think they have to become an
entrepreneur it's so on trend it's so
what you should do and you know I think
a lot of people are leaving a lot of
money on the table by but not being a
number two and number three and number
four and number eleven because they're
awesome at that it's a very different
game than being the founder of something
and then I just think regret right like
if you do if you went the other way and
you've always been in the company and
it's always kind of been there like your
grandma was an entrepreneur you're kind
of like you're like maybe like you just
want to be you really want to try to
project that when you're laying there at
95 you're not like [ __ ] why for just
those two years didn't I start that
peanut butter company or you know
knitting thing to me to me those are two
words that I would be playing over and
over do you actually know yourself and
know what you're good at and what you're
built for and - do you feel comfortable
that you won't look back everybody here
in the mat and there's some youngsters
in here but everybody here is already
sitting with two three four things they
can think of very quickly that they
regret right now already you've got a
lot more life to go and right now you
feel okay because you've got a lot of
life to go but if you spend time with
people in their 80s and 90s the thing
they will absolutely teach you if you
really dig is regret [ __ ] sucks and
so that's the one thing I would hover
and the back of your mind as well
yeah oh yeah you talked a lot about
self-awareness yes you know I've been
through many different careers
yes I did you do is there a process or
an ability that you can't you to figure
out like what you want like what I don't
know like I'm yes I'm sorry
I'd love to hi I don't know I really
don't like I know it's important yeah I
just don't know the answer to the
question right like I don't know how I
don't know how to like help somebody
understand what they want I really don't
I really I I think about it a lot
because I want to yeah I don't but I
think I do think it has a lot to do with
honesty okay like the purest form of
being truthful to yourself versus who
you wish you were there's a very
important point
yeah that's true you know what I mean
yeah like are you look like like are you
willing to be super honest with yourself
when nobody's watching we all know who
we are sometimes we don't like that
right nobody wants to be like oh I'm
kind of average and that you know but
that is where the that's where it is
it's not me where am I it's been good
East I know you're down there I want to
take the chance come I will tell you
yeah see I feel so weird we're always
together I miss you so much
[Music]